theme music just never gets old I love
it I love it so who here wants to hear
more about voxels yeah miles does miles
does he wants to hear more about voxels
so the next issue that reared its ugly
head was the fact that many commercial
software products use volumetric data
however they had a hard time working
together previously you had to take the
data from one system and write a bespoke
method for pulling it into a different
system this made it hard for VFX studios
to exchange the data with each other
field 3d and open source software became
a bridge for volumetric data allowing
artists to use their favorite tools
while sharing data between the different
systems it's all about sharing data what
does that even mean I don't know for
creating field 3d which provided a
flexible and open framework for
assessing voxel data the Academy
presents Magnus running up with a
technical achievement award come on out
come on up
thank you and first of all let me thank
the Academy and the saitek committee for
for acknowledging our project it's a
great honor they say it takes a village
to raise a child well it takes a little
programmer village two to make a project
like this meaningful so first of all I'd
like to thank the people that have
worked with me on Phil 3d particular
such music posse and chris allen also
Robredo who encouraged encouraged us
early on to make this project open
source Barbara foreground for running
the team back in the early days but I'd
especially like to thank all the people
that have work to make feel 3d part of
their pipelines especially Rob PK at MPC
and his company has done a lot of work
using him I'd like to thank under Sunnah
man Doug Roble and Darren grant for
opening the door and getting me started
in this industry and my parents when I
can't tell us my brother Jonas my
children and ice and Oscar and most of
all to my wife jackie i would like to
thank you profoundly for supporting me
all these years thank you so much